ya know and welcome to this video we
playing a 15 minute game here on RCC and
I'm back after about four days off
without a new upload and this is because
I caught a really bad cold and for for
like - two or three days I couldn't
couldn't speak almost and now it's um
it's better it's not back to normal but
at least I feel good enough to to play
game um yeah I've got a Queens gambit
accepted him um go for solid line before
is also fine but let's say I want to
keep it simple and probably if they
would make me do a drug test I wouldn't
I wouldn't get a positive a good result
from that as I'm still on medication
against this against this cold ok played
860m you know probably I'm trying to
prepare b5 not not sure if I'm what I
should do I mean he fought some kind of
normal move here looks normal but
probably be 5 from this playable I don't
see him how I would get my pawn back
then I could play a form yeah I think
just a phone keep it simple should
should be okay hmm
yeah this is so interesting yeah there
are some some funny ideas in those kind
of positions if I go we form this may be
the possibility that he that he can take
on a form sacrificing a knight and
taking then on d5 this is a valid idea
sometimes to get them a big porn upon
rola in the center yeah and after this
yeah
if ifs em it's normal really yeah I
think I should w5 not sure 94 no I think
this is probably a known position at
least it's certainly a known position
without a 4 and a 6 plate and I'm not
entirely sure what this is yeah what
this is some with this what the meaning
compared to without a 4 and a 6 but the
good thing is I don't even know her and
he think about the position without the
moves so yeah what couldn't like do it I
mean you can go to d7 looks rather
passive but suddenly a move that that
can be played Bishop g5 probably or I
could just take what the Queen 194 this
is a the principled alternative which I
could take take on the 895 get my pawn
back and this is in fact a line where
the insertion of a 4 and a 6 might be
might be something for white at the end
of all this yeah maybe see 5 or 7 as a
possible weakness I'm not sure though I
could also just take on d5 after which
you probably would take on c3
yeah I think I'll go I go for this
change an IG 5 yeah I'm pawned down but
I attack f7e 4 and C 4 so I'll get them
at least one pawn bag
in fact in them at the moment I'm two
points down but but I get I get to get
them back as soon as I mentioned yeah
Bishop is c4 now I guess and a Bishop e6
was also a possibility for him I guess
now here to threaten or f7 and I can
just take you for also next move
it's not clear also how how does he
defend f7 no he could play a move like
f6 but yeah yeah so what do I do now I
can um yeah I could take two times only
six or take this should be 6f e 94 this
looks a bit a bit weak though maybe to
take two times here with the noise I
Bishop takes every 96 threatening 97 and
probably it needs to make some yeah some
silly King moves to to address that idea
you can probably this is why it should
be it should be very good for me
how does he prevent even IG 54 and then
I'm a pound pawn up at the end even we
gained three pawns oops
yeah I could just why should they take
the rook
black ears yeah sort of a mismatch of
course it's just rated 1700 but this is
the issue with the auto pairing here you
um get completely yeah not random
opponents but if they are relatively few
in this 15 minute pool then you might
get far weaker position at times I try
to to get another game quickly and then
the pool though that I can combine this
into a two game video um yeah black in
fact them has huge problems here already
I think I mean could could be wrong but
I don't think he can get a decent
position here and he must play as
something to cover c7 probably this move
probably this move and then I just
dropped back here and we'll we'll get
the porn and that's a time that
something like this
and different circuit you should be for
coming maybe even immediately imagine
game started okay I get him against
another game here so I'll combine this
into two game video or one e-form what
did I play a recently I played the card
I played the French okay let's start
with the Sicilian and decide later what
what line to play not a three okay so at
least it looks like an open Sicilian
yeah it's pretty high rated playing some
may be a trifle some line with E 5 like
the Kalashnikov all the sveshnikov it
depends if he plays some 1 3 d 4 no he
does I take ya know if I would be the
the so called Kalashnikov variation it's
really unclear why this this name has
been attached to it but actually maybe
should should be called them yeah well
you've got a 595 then a sixes the the
classical variation here which has been
played even in the 1800s and 1900s got
the little variation if I'm not mistaken
and d6 is the modern treatment which has
been more or less popular popularized by
Afghani especially cough who thinks that
this is much better than its original
line the the well-known specially called
variation ok yeah I played this a couple
of times but I don't really know the
exact theory I hope I can get by
with with natural kind of moves the
ethic 95 or something I need to attend
to so let let's get rid of this this
night should I play Bishop g5 or
shouldn't I do this I'm not sure maybe I
can I can first get some development
move in
yep the pawn structures indeed term
similar to the regular especially cough
the difference is that why discipline
seafoam like him do to see form isn't
able to play you could be left as he is
able to disrespect off but the c-4
pardon is not yeah just an advantage for
wide in terms of preventing b5 but also
problem as it makes his f1 Bishop pretty
pretty bad piece at the moment white
beads to be cautious that he doesn't run
into some scenario where his bishop is
bad on f1 and blacks Bishop is finally
six so on it is a positionally very very
interesting opening it can often um get
yeah it was very interesting maneuvering
where the proper exchange of pieces are
self as essential black would like to
get rid of his dark squared bishop with
Bishop g5 probably this also was an idea
both ago and I'm not quite sure about
the theoretical details here I just
thought that I can play this move anyway
next like smooth and this is why I
didn't hurry with this alright quite
interesting to see what what is coming
up now probably just bishop somewhere
there should be two on Knight see - I'm
not sure
aha the instant 95 this is in fact
interesting hmm okay so one point of
this is obviously I came to play Bishop
g5 as this was blunder blunder here on
c7 so the CEO he did prevent so this is
a pretty early point to move the noid
one question is after Knight f6 what
what is he doing he for his hanging does
he play f3 really are did I take some
knight X his heaven cannot be a big
issue for me
now maybe after Knight f6 he can play
Bishop III could be a possibility
intending Knight b6 or Bishop Derby 6
even in Bishop e6 night that's his son
nest or not f6 should be should be
alright let's see how he reacts if he
plays something like f3 ad I think I
should be fine yeah okay this was was
one possible idea of his some of his
whole setup I thought that I could just
97 if everything else fails
another question is what is this really
doing I mean if I just Castle what
what's the big big point we should be
six Queen to d7 and I could go 97 but
this is all very time-consuming so why
shouldn't that castle really yeah that's
just Castle and now he for some the same
aha interesting I didn't think that this
what would do him much good but maybe
I'm saying assessing the sir
and the wrong way I'm not sure I just
feel that I'm much better developed now
and not sure that this Bishop on b67 was
so great one one idea could be Bishop to
d8 just try to exchange this piece
yeah this is probably not not bad at all
Bishop t8 he could play Knight f6 then I
could just recapture and I don't see
that that I should have any big problems
could also first mm yeah not sure I
thought about first moving the knight on
f6 and then play Bishop to d8
hmm okay let's do this first
you can go Knight f6 but then I don't
know is what well this is a very strange
reaction I think especially as he played
this instantly all right so let's let's
see what we can do here I think this
must be technically at least somewhat
dubious I don't think this is good okay
but let's have a look if I take on d5
this is obviously the critical move on
one of the to capture sir
because if I just take on d5 with any
piece ante what recapture I would take
b6 that have a great position with a
pawn and have a dominant Bishop on on
b6o let's say 95 he what you would need
to take on d8 and then I have
possibilities like Knight f4 I'm
thinking about something like this 95
Bishop d89 f4 and then the bishop needs
to move on d8 if he moves to some some
silly place I don't know let's say b6
again then I have stuff like Bishop to
h3 taking G to G takes h3 Queen f3 and
it's made on g2 yeah 95
t89 f4 and Bishop h3 but he's got Bishop
to g5 which which saves him of course it
didn't calculate any of this he just
played played this instantly and it's
lucky that this is not working otherwise
this would wince would win just just
instantly okay so I can take here he
takes on d8 right there for Knight
Bishop g5 yeah this is this is saving
for white of course I have no problem
second I can play this also I could take
on d5 with the bishop you know this is
of course also a possibility take with
the bishop takes on d8 rook e8
recaptures in 94 and I'm just I'm just
fine yeah multitude of possibilities
it's a shame that this 95 isn't winning
outright because of the silly Bishop g5
move okay so let's let's play this as a
simple ant leads to a good good position
so TG claim
okay question is how to take now
probably with the Queen because queen to
be six can be can be a good good
resource night eggs looks looks it looks
very yet so let's take here the ideas
could be six for example of if I go
after taking only five I go to the far
right and if you then place f4 at some
point a cut will be six
I hope I didn't miss a direct refutation
castles really as the see every was a
yet move especially played them
instantly
so let's see what what he does now okay
so I'm of course I don't want to eat
wheat yeah this I thought would be
answered with we'd be six but he's
obviously not afraid of this yeah I'm
always amazed that people play very very
committed moose instantly like castles
and FRR obviously this is all so easy
and and obvious to play I always need a
bit of time to really think about things
not sure what did sir but this meets
okay Queen to b6 yeah maybe he can take
only five it's possible some technical
justification of all this
yes though I hope I have some some
defensive NIDA 3 is also a possibility
after taking so that I have a night only
five he can then think about sacrificing
on f6 but there should be at best at
wrong what I'm talking about is takes
here yeah also played quickly yeah I'm
Nydia three double check King in the
corner and then 95 he might think about
ruk f6 and takes and then queen h5 but I
have d3 is hanging I should I should
have enough defensive resources really
it's a really a good good piece on e5
yeah if he's not able to sack on f6 now
but sure what he is going to go into
play between singing or not on a 3 SL
really a bad piece
yeah it's not so easy to make a kind of
slow move here I also maybe have the
idea to play Knight to g4
after g4 9 f 293 those kind of ideas
it's probably I'm not faithful for what
if I would do that but something to
think of he 3 is not not a great spot
really yeah he would like to play Queen
to D forward east and he has a track of
course so hard to continue one
possibility is some Knight to d7 night
to this d7 to c5 this kind of idea
taking I don't know doesn't seem to
create a me his God also before as some
some option okay let's play a simple
move 48 which just introduces the idea
of sometimes even just taking on d3 take
Andrew p3 what
this looks a strange to me too ok it
Cavis be too but it leaves the other
night in a somewhat hanging position
that would play not f2g for now or
threatened on d3 yeah I probably
retreated but take on d3 rookie 3 yeah
okay this is certainly good food like
but not sure if it's the best
continuation okay come on I don't want
to waste them more time I'm down on the
clock and want to catch up a bit it
doesn't help that it doesn't help to
lose some time at the end if you call
all the opponent's moves strange and
weird and so on and what's the
justification it doesn't help if you
lose some time at the end okay I just
have to e-file now which should be worth
something
okay yeah where to put the rock a good
question maybe if form 2 to keep the the
night passive rookie 2 is also
possibility then you might play 90 for
them maybe just him this keeps the
lighter completely inactive on c2 it
cannot move it anywhere and this intense
energy form piling up on f2 and so on
came
so 92 no rookie to now attacking the
night where does it go not sure maybe
you can play a rook - you won
yeah maybe you can play up to even
trying to exchange lots of stuff but I
think I can just then exchange on you
want multiple terms of like win a 5 or
24 sort of in waiting and then
introducing the idea of 94 I should
should be good then with them the better
pieces better activity
yeah this pressure on f7 it's a bit of a
nuisance if I would be able to okay so
let's just exchange them
yeah okay I was considering this and now
I thought Queen D for Queen a five Queen
a 5-wood double attack you won at a -
not so clear
hi what camera this Queen e2 probably
yeah Queenie - I like I like windy form
with the idea of playing Knight e4 and
this would on a g4 I'm not sure what's
better but try to coordinate those two
pieces and trying to get something
against the King yet some yam 94 I guess
it's pretty clear that black should be
better in some to some extent but it's
not not easy to tell if this is
something yeah something serious or just
optically better
I mean sometimes some positions look
good but it's hard to make any any
progress and this might be one of those
so possible okay let's use this this
check to to gain a move and then play a
five you know probably just at five or
is there some some other idea Knight 92
yeah probably just Queen f2 don't think
it let amounts to much let's move the F
pawn
yet in two minutes two minutes against
four minutes
yeah it looks nice but it's hard to tell
if I'm able to to make any any of you
progress here maybe it it's just solid
enough for a draw for white
a plane Bishop Knight to t2 probably I
can can repeat moves you know this also
threatens g5 yeah it's a to how to think
I'm too long to play for wynia just
because of the time
I would happily try to play for for win
but with the time it's very tricky
check
don't don't see how to how to try to win
really Queenie won maybe between you
won't have to
oh come on let's let's let's try this I
don't think I'm risking too much him
Knight to d2
neide f1 jack
hmm
shouldn't the some be good now
Queen takes g3 and I grab on on their
form
time warning check
Oh 92 another night on this night on f1
doesn't have much squares whoo yeah I
can go here but then he probably has
some checks here okay go in check here
but I can I can go to h6 problem it's
not not clear that this really helps
them I learned threatening neither three
hmm yeah
tricky yeah at the end he's got c5 at
the end he's got c5 very unlucky I could
maybe answered may I just should have
taken the draw now it's got C 5 and wins
a completely undeserved win Yeah right
this promotes yeah of course this wasn't
necessary to lose and I could have found
probably one easel yet more than one
point and no this is just it should be
it should be good really may be it may
be this just so wrong yeah yeah of
course King g8 is a draw I cannot to do
anything else than check I didn't have
much tied just saw this too late
lettuce cut this to see five at the end
and of course this this kind of stuff is
just better for black
I just spent too much time here can just
just play about anything
a5 b5 why this it's not able to do much
she's just clearly clearly worse with
the the goodnight on only for this what
I tried is probably due to this long
line which wasn't possible to calculate
before so just a draw and this is what I
played of course losing it I saw it
pretty pretty pretty quickly but I just
they're just too late
yeah always a bit of a shame if the
white player didn't do anything in this
game was just worse all the way but you
overlooked something and you lose this
is this is chess that happens especially
if you're if you're down on time he
played rather quickly
at least quicker quicker than I was
young in several positions I think there
were possibilities of of better and
better play let's say he a computer just
wants to retake on e5 with the plea
advantage for black yeah this is
certainly possible b2 is hanging and I
always wanted to have this brilliant
knight on e5 okay the computer also
gives black a clearly close to winning
advantage already here this is a bit
much but yeah yeah this is all
orchid any better for black
yeah somewhere along here with some
question how wide should defend hard to
tell
also h3 was a really weird move but ok
why would you play h3 when you can play
G 3 which was much more logical and
spawn structure why weak in the dark
squares even more ok yeah Mia this is
this sometimes just happens the opponent
was just basically doing nothing and you
overlooked one thing and you lose this
is today
it's the way this game is played all
right yeah thanks for watching I hope
you enjoyed it anyway it was an
interesting game yeah I hope to be be
updating regularly now again as I'm
becoming a yeah fit again I hope at
least my voice is back yeah thanks for
watching